[Music]
amd's RX 7900 XT has finally become the
competitor it should have been sort of
it's time to do a revisit because the
pricing has been shuffling a lot lately
and depending on which price we're
looking at it's become a lot more
competitive than it was it's been all
over the place though we bought this RX
7900 XT hellhound by powercolor when it
was
$720 that was a $30 instant promo
stacked on top of a $750 Baseline price
apparently that was an incredibly narrow
window though because by the time we
finished our in-depth testing of the
card and writing the review which was
only about 2 weeks the price had changed
and not just the promo price the entire
price on all the US retailers we checked
the price climbed from 720 discounted
and 750 Baseline to new $800 Baseline
that's down from $900 MSRP so in either
case it's reduced it's just that change
took us by surprise because
every retail listing we saw gave us the
impression that 750 was going to be the
new Baseline price because that was the
strike through number the the number
that's normally a lie that retailers
just put there and they strike it
through and they say no it's this price
that was the one that was stricken
through it's gone up from there so uh
we're skeptical whether the price may
have just briefly been bumped up before
Black Friday to then drop down again to
the price we bought this card at but
we'll see what happens when we hit Black
Friday in a few weeks and either event
though the price is lower than it was a
year ago when we reviewed the 7800 XT so
it is time to do a revisit on this and
the price we bought it at that be $180
decline from the launch MSRP or if you
were to buy it right now it's a $100
drop from launch MSRP and both are a big
shift so let's get started before that
this video is brought to you by Lexar
Thor memory lexar's new Thor ddr5 and
ddr4 RAM includes a heavyduty aluminum
heat spreader while retaining a
relatively low profile form factor for
PCs with air cooler clearance the Lexar
Thor memory supports both Expo and Intel
XMP timings and is available from ddr5
5600 to ddr5 6000 cl32 learn more at the
link in the description below at launch
we called the card a greedy upsell and
we said that AMD was out of touch with
its own pricing of the 6950 XT which at
the time and still today was the better
value of the two but the 6950 XT is
almost gone and it won't be restocked at
this point either way with the price
drop and then climb despite our
immeasurable disappointment from which
our days were ruined will Forge ahead
with the video rewrite anyway and we'll
approach this from two perspectives one
is the Assumption of an $800 Baseline
and the other one is the Assumption of a
$720 $750 Baseline if it comes back down
and for those of you in Europe we have
some price data for you as well we get
to either price would put the 700 XT in
close competition with nvidia's RTX 470
TI that that's going to be our main
point to focus on today is the value and
the head-to-head comparisons so this
piece is meant to be more of a
convenient buyers guide looking at some
quick top level Recaps relative scaling
percentages against the most nearby and
relevant competitors to the 7900 XT and
especially the hellhound model that we
tested here uh so we'll start with the
prices as of October 30th and then we'll
briefly look at the prices from a couple
weeks ago when we bought the car first
off looking at camel camel camel a price
comparison engine we happened to buy the
cards right in this narrow dip it didn't
last long but the $850 Baseline seems to
be Vanishing so that's at least a move
in the right direction doing a quick
search on newag and Amazon uh using
first party only shipped and sold cards
and factoring in instant promos but
ignoring mail and rebates and gifts we
end up with the prices you're seeing now
most recently the 7an XT it seems to
land around $800 that's unfortunate it's
still better but again if you look at
the column for October 13th it was much
cheaper just a few weeks ago this was
mostly reflected on Amazon as well but
new EG was the best place to find those
prices at that time looking at the 4070
TI the prices are largely unchanged this
past month for both major retailers in
the US overall the 4070 TI can commonly
be found for around $800 so the 7900 XT
at its new price is the direct
competitor and as of October 30th it
doesn't have a big pricing Advantage if
it drops back to 720 it it will but it's
not there right now the few $770 470 TI
that we found out there would have a
slight pricing Advantage here finally
looking at the 470 non TI you'd be able
to find this card for around $550 with
relative ease or definitely at 600 plus
in the US but there's a more important
alternative in this price class and it's
a close competitor to amd's 7900 XT the
6950 XT is almost completely gone at
this point we found five total
first-party listings between newag and
Amazon they appeared to have a couple
units in stock at least we'll link them
below but AMD is almost definitely not
making this card anymore and it's on its
way out it's unfortunate though because
at $600 it's a killer price compared to
the 7800 XT and the 4070 TI but we still
need to look at how the 700 XT is today
especially since again these cards will
be replaced by the 79 XT we also pulled
up the RTX 480 and we were shocked at
how expensive it has remained we also
found it poetic that Newegg confused an
RTX 470 TI with an RTX 480 considering
that's what it was originally called and
we know not all of you are in the US so
we did our best to aggregate some data
for Europe as well Galls helped us with
this they catered to Germany Austria and
Switzerland and provide mountains of
pricing data and trend line information
we asked Galls to utilize its price
trend data to help us show the price
reduction since launch and they were
awesome to quickly get us this chart
this chart includes 19% value added tax
plus European pricing and it's in Euros
so for our Americans in the audience
Europe has bigger number it's leveled
off in terms of the decline but it's
still lower than launch a guol shared
data with us that showed the best priced
700 XTS in its regions including the XFX
MC with 32 offers and Sapphire poles
powercolor might not have the same
distribution advantages in Europe
because hellhound is €20 over the XFX
card there now this data is from just
before the recent price hikes in the US
so we're not sure if that's also true in
Europe now we'll go over the quick
competitive comparisons before we go
over the more detailed charts this chart
shows a top level recap of average FPS
scaling across several recently tested
scenarios a bar to the right is
Improvement for the 7900 XT and a bar to
the left is percentage performance
reduction against the 4070 ti so if the
bar goes left then the 470 TI is winning
uh remember percent math is a little
funny so we position these in a way that
is generally showing percent in increase
unless the loss is just so big that it
shows up like this the rx700 XT has the
majority of Victories here and most of
them are double digit the skylines 2
test was particularly wild although that
game is one of the worst optimized games
we've ever tested in a long time but
it's still a valid test because it's a
real scenario even if the game just
isn't built that well in rate tracing
test the 700 XT runs 3% to 9% worse the
lower Nvidia advantages are at 4K here
where nvidia's are architectural choices
have limited the 470 TI's ability to
continue scaling the 4070 TI also had
breakouts and rasterization and Final
Fantasy at 1080P and 1440p the card
scaled further before it hit the CPU
limit the 700 XT seemed to encounter a
mixture of driver overhead limitation
and CPU limitation for these lower
resolutions in this game it appears
there's a driver overhead advantage in
this particular title with this CPU for
NVIDIA in Counter-Strike 2 Nvidia just
has a legitimate Advantage right now so
this establishes that Nvidia for the
most part maintains a rate tracing
Advantage but AMD holds a strong
advantage in rasterization and in higher
resolution testing specifically its
overall capabilities at 4K are
relatively speaking greater than the
4070 TI and that's due to some
architectural choices that Nvidia made
this past generation so the biggest
disadvantage of the 7900 XT originally
was the price that was resolved in a
huge way where it was less of a question
as to how the value was when was $720
$750 so if you see that price come back
and nothing else around it really moves
then it once again becomes a very good
value comparatively right now the 700 XT
and the 4070 TI are about the same price
but if you want really R Trace heavy and
that's most of what you play then you
should more strongly consider the 4070
TI than you might if you were largely on
rasterized gaming or especially at
rasterized in 4k gaming let's look at
the 470 versus the 700 XT we're adding
this so so that you know what you'd gain
by spending an extra $270 or so the
700xt maintains an advantage in the 40
to 50% range for many of these games
when at 4K the 1080p results are often
CPU bound hence the lower scaling in R
tracing we're seeing a maximum 29%
Advantage for the 700 XT the 470 holds a
6% lead in Final Fantasy 14 for our
testing indicating the same CPU bound
Behavior Advantage we saw in the 470 TI
but only at 1080p overall then whether
we look at the cheapest or the average
cost from our earlier pricing tables the
price increased to $720 to $750 would be
about 35 to 38% or so for the 700 XT
over the 470 that is and that's for a 40
to 50% increase in 4k and 1440p
performance or if we look at the new
pricing of $800 the 700 XT is about 45%
more expensive so it loses some of that
value Advantage it had but it's still a
lot better than the $900 price that it
was originally at we'll next look at the
7800 XTX against the 7800 XT the pric in
here was as low as $890 with General
availability at $900 now it's generally
available at
$950 with several cards boosting over a
grand we're not sure what happened but
everything jumped for amd's card prices
for these two cards here's a comparison
chart the bar represents percent uplift
for the XTX over the XT generally
speaking we're seeing about a 20% uplift
at 4K for the upgrade 1440p tends to be
around 15% and 1080p is less reliable
because again a lot of these games start
truncating the results as of the October
13th pricing that would have been a $170
or so increase to buy the XTX or 24%
more money cheapest to cheapest in
exchange for 20% more 4K performance
that's for the XTX now at $800 Baseline
for the XT against $950 Baseline for the
XTX that's A9 % cost increase so it's
gotten closer this isn't as linear as we
see lower down the stack so you're
starting to pay for the just the best
premium for the XTX remember you'd also
need to begin considering the 4080 if
you're in this pricing because it starts
to pop up nearer the XTX than the XT
although you could always keep playing
the but if I just spend $100 more a game
and you'd eventually end up at the 490
if you talked yourself into that overall
we'd say that the value of the 700 XT is
improving as opposed to its original
value positioning against the XTX where
it was more clearly an upsell but again
it's tough to make a hard call when the
prices are jumping so much if we were at
that 720 to 750 range of the XT and the
range of the XTX we showed then we'd say
the XT is the better value right now but
as the prices grow closer to each other
we start falling back into that upsell
potential scenario that's a better spot
than the XT was in at launch at least
for relative value against competitors
but it was nearly an undeniable victory
at the price 2 weeks ago other than the
6950 XT as an alternative but we want to
make sure the cheapest options are
actually any good so we ran some basic
thermal power and frequency tests on the
hellhound because that was the cheapest
one and we wouldn't want to save a few
bucks if it's a bad card so let's look
at that this card has dual V bios which
is typically a feature associated with
much more expensive cards so it's
actually great to see this gives you a
backup in case the firmware ever gets
bricked it gives you some more
flexibility if you did want to try and
modify this and overclock it with a
custom V bios and it should also just be
a quality of life Improvement so quickly
evaluating the frequency here we found
the ocv BIOS ran at about 2484 MHz when
at steady state so it drops around 90
MHz from the start of the test due to
heat gain the silent V bios appears to
work this time we've had issues with
power color messing that up in the past
and the clocks drop to 2390 MHz this is
a big reduction but it's intended to
reduce fan speed by reducing Heat load
from the GPU so that's the trade for
silent mode we'd strongly recommend
starting with OC mode though which is
default from the factory if the fan
speed bothers you you can always set it
to silent after that you would just
reboot in between thermal performance
has long been a challenge for partner
models with amd's more recent
Generations mostly for the hotspot
thermals in this test the ocv BIOS had
the card running at about 70° CSUS Edge
temperature with hot spot at about 84°
it's well within spec far better than
we've seen on on some of the reference
designs it's not the best performer
we've encountered and it's less capable
than say the Nitro overall but it's also
the cheapest we've tested so far and
it's still performing in a way that
doesn't concern us when it comes to
thermals the silent V bios doesn't
really change the temperature much
that's because powercolor dropped the
frequency so we're trading some
frequency for lower fan speed however
the fan speed actually only came down by
a couple percentage points here so
there's more that they could do to
properly capitalize on the word silent
and their vbios naming although we did
notice some odd hysteresis uh behaviors
with the fan speed in general so power
color could do more tuning there for
power consumption the rx700 XT reference
card was at about 3133 Watts when we
first reviewed it with an overclock
Landing it at 362 Watts the hellhound
ran at 309 Watts for silent V bios and
330 on the default ocv bios but without
us overclocking that would naturally
increase it further so it's a little bit
over over the reference 7900 XT but
that's expected for a partner model in
most instances the RTX 4070 TI ran at
290 watts in the tough default
performance Fe bios which is
significantly lower than the 330 we're
seeing on the default for hellhound so
that alongside some of the rate tracing
disadvantages is one of the other
disadvantages of going with the 700xt
rather than a 4070 TI you're trading
some of that RT performance and some of
that power and performance efficiency
for the price as as for the 7800 XTX the
reference model pulled about 351 Watts
when stock the point of this revisit was
again to provide the sort of
head-to-head top level recap as a buyer
guide leading into the end of the year
when a lot of people are building PCS
but we know a lot of you like a flood of
data with a ton of charts uh so we're
going to look at a couple of the full
gaming charts with all of the cards
we've recently tested on them and to get
these in complete depth if you want
every single one of them you can check
out our recent RX 7800 XT review or our
a580 use for all of them but let's speed
through a couple of them here well look
at Starfield first this one has had an
overall AMD Advantage for gpus in
Starfield at 4K High we had the 700 XTX
at 74 FPS average and the 7900 XT at 64
FPS average that's a 15% improvement
with the XTX the 480 is left in the Dust
by the XTX which has a 27% lead and the
XT has an 11% lead this depends a lot on
the game of course so remember it won't
always look like this the XT shows that
it can definitely be a 4K gaming card
especially without rage racing against
something cheaper like the 7800 XT we're
seeing that the 7900 XT has about a 32%
lead for about $300 more money that's a
sharp loss in performance per dollar
with the 700xt as compared to the 78 XT
but it also moves performance into a
different category where you're going to
start changing settings with that
reduction at 1440p the 700 XT and XTX
are about the same that's because we're
now approaching a CPU bind in this title
so let's move on just because brand new
data let's briefly look at the
impressively buggy City skylines 2 which
has bugs as bad as inverse Graphics
settings at higher presets we just ran a
full benchmark test and graphics
comparison for this game that you can
find on the channel if you want more
this starts at 1080P and don't get us
wrong it won't go up from here the game
is functionally unplayable at high
resolutions it's like 2009 all over
again before the patch the 700 XT was
around 60 FPS average with these
settings lows are all over the place but
that's the game and it's universally
true for the cards the XTX is about 11%
better here the lead over the 4070 TI is
about 30% as we showed earlier the 7800
XT Gap is similar it's $300 less once
again and that would land you at 46 FPS
average with these settings instead the
480 is down at 57 FPS average we'll
briefly look at F1 2022 now but using
raate tracing for the testing at 1440p
and Ultra with raate tracing the 700 XT
ran at about 85 to 86 FPS average that
has the hell just behind the 4070 TI
here so we're seeing the ranks flip as
expected the 4070 TI holds an advantage
with rt tests it's about 5% for the 4070
TI the XTX is about 14% ahead of the XT
here in Shadow of the Tomb Raider at 4K
High the 700 XT ran at about 123 to 127
FPS average that has the XTX about 177%
ahead the RTX 480 is roughly tied with
that with the 490 establishing a ceiling
the 4070 TI isn't too far back with the
700 XT ahead by 5% to 88.5% depending on
which card you look at the 6950 XT
remains compelling value here with
nearly equal performance to the 4070 TI
but a $200 cheaper price we'll quickly
look at balers Gate 3 now this game
isn't intensive enough for a card like
the 700 XT to be fully leveraged and
established a significant lead over some
of its closest Alternatives but that's
kind of the point we're showing this
game because it shows you that scenario
at 4K Ultra the 700 XT is CPU bound and
rank to alongs side the 700 XTX the RTX
480 and the RTX 490 the 4070 TI and the
6950 XT are nearby we wanted to show
this chart again because it helps put
into perspective what you really need if
you're playing less intensive games like
this one you could save a lot of money
by dropping down to something like a
6800 XT a 7800 XT or an RTX 470 or even
lower than this you don't have to buy
this highend either all these cards are
relatively highend but the cost
reduction is massive so those are the
broken out fully detailed charts with
all the cards on them and again you can
get more of these in our 7800 XT or a580
reviews if you want all of them but
we've shown you the condensed head toad
charts within some of them around a
dozen games for the percent scaling
already in a much faster fashion earlier
getting into the concluding thoughts
here on the 7900 XT it's definitely a
different position than it was a year
ago first up though a quick note if all
this has been helpful to you please head
over to store. Gamers access.net and
grab one of our 3D debug coaster packs
these help help fund our data collection
and our testing directly and you get a
highquality pack of useful PC Hardware
themed coasters in return each pack
comes with four distinct drink coasters
all using a soft and flexible material
with great texturing these include a
motherboard with PGA socket and seven
segment debug power and reset buttons on
it and a vrm heat sink molded into the
coaster design and it's all spaced
precisely to support your glass wear and
drinks the level of detail we achieved
on these when we were designing them is
crazy even the memory module coaster has
small pin holes next to the dim pins
there's also a SATA SSD coaster where we
designed into the border the pins for
the SATA drive and there's a GN logo
with a smoothly transitioned gradient
these are easy to clean highly durable
and they'll keep your tabl stylish and
protected from condensation and they
help us keep running in-depth pieces
like this so head over to store Gamers
access.net to grab a pack and thank you
for your support and purchases cuz it
helps us keep doing all of this content
as we've continued to increase our depth
of things back to the 7900 XT recapping
the value at the temporary price the
7900 XT was one of the best values for a
high-end current generation gaming card
so just briefly here we're ignoring the
presence of some of the last gen stuff
that has been on and off available uh we
were excited about the card at
$720 the powercolor hellhound was easy
to recommend relatively speaking and
even at 750 it wasn't too bad but those
prices didn't last the the only reason
it's worth repeatedly mentioning this is
because again we're highly suspicious of
the price climb in such close proximity
to Black Friday which if you don't know
if you don't live in the US it's our
most sacred holiday here in America
where we celebrate consumerism it's
coming up soon and we wouldn't be
surprised if the cards drop again and if
they do and if the competition doesn't
similarly drop in say the 4070 TI then
the 7900 XT would become the best value
in its price class for a current gen
card currently however that award
remains with the 6950 XT which won't
last sadly but at $600 these are one of
the best cards you can buy right now at
the highend there are only a few left at
us retailers that we found at Major
retailers we link the ones we found
below uh but unfortunately because it's
last gen AMD almost certainly isn't
going to make more of them and more
likely because it cannibalizes their
sales H it's just doesn't seem like
they're going to keep making cards that
undercut their their current alternative
to the 6950 XT by hundreds of dollars if
you do happen to grab one though the
differences between these are often plus
or minus 5% from the 700 XT with the max
range at around 10% Although our
enthusiasm around the 700 XT has
tempered with the price reincrease it is
now still in direct competition with the
4070 TI whereas with the original MSRP
it would have been about $100 above
where the 4070 TI is is right now so a
couple things to recap here the 470 TI
has advantages in rate tracing
particularly when at lower resolutions
like 1080p that Advantage starts to
evaporate as you go on higher
resolutions which is just a an AR again
an architectural choice where AMD is
doing better there right now kind of odd
because it used to be the case that
Nvidia would do better there the 4070 TI
might also have a feature set Advantage
it depends on what you play so if you
play games like like a cyberpunk is
going to be a major title for you that
you plan to spend 100 plus hours in or
something like that you should really
consider Nvidia because it has Ray
reconstruction which we did a whole
separate video on now uh we have some
examples of where it really doesn't look
good so you'll want to look at that in
detail and and check if it's actually a
feature you care about but if you think
it looks good overall then it's a
potential slight performance bump at
least in that title uh and it changes
how the game looks in a way that's
difficult to compare head-to head
because now it's getting into image
quality additionally nvidia's got wider
adoption of features like dlss frame
generation so you'll need to research
those and see if you care about them we
have some videos on all this stuff and
uh AMD does have FSR 3 and fluid motion
now which is its own frame generation
just not as widespread at this point and
then nvidia's got reflex to consider as
well AMD has anti-ag plus kind of but it
retracted it it'll come back probably
anyway our original thoughts on the 7900
XT were clear uh we said it was a greedy
upsell and at the original laun
positioning it absolutely was cuz they
were trying to push people to the XTX if
they were buying either Card
unfortunately the price changes have
contracted the XTX and XT closer
together once again they were briefly
more distant but they've come back
closer uh we also noted in the original
review that the 6950 XT and the 6900 XT
were far better values the 6900 XT is
basically gone at this point we couldn't
really find any new in stock from a
first party uh the major retailers we
look at but the 6950x remains around at
$600 and is our first choice at this
sort of high end if you're okay giving
up a couple percentage points of
performance for significant Savings in
price now ultimately the 7900 XT is in a
far better position competitively than
it was at launch and it's worth
considering now at the very high end and
we're going to keep looking at these
over the next month or so as we kind of
recap the gpus that have been out this
year or the last year uh and help you
figure out which one to buy at different
price points but in the very least it's
better positioned we'd probably maybe h
a little bit to see if that price comes
back down to 720 CU again you know this
whole video was done and we were excited
about it at
$720 it's an expensive video card like
in an absolute sense it's very expensive
especially compared to the old days of
$500 $600 flagships but compared to the
other offerings on the market it was an
exciting price drop and it's just it's
hard to be quite as excited now again
with that feeling of the rug was pulled
where it was like cool we got it for 720
bucks let's tell everyone about this and
look at it and see if it's worth it
and that's not the price anymore so uh
anyway it's still down we'll see if it
comes down again but hopefully that
recap helps you get back up to speed on
the market thanks for watching and if
you have other cards you want us to look
at specifically in the next month or two
let us know cuz we're doing revisits
right now so we have the bandwidth for
it uh and when I say that I mean not
just like current stuff but if you want
us to revisit a 10 ser Ser card 20 30
series cards let us know which ones
upvote each other so we can see what
people have that they would be most
benefited by us revisiting because uh
for those of you who are in a position
where you want to upgrade you probably
want to know how the positioning
compares to what you have now and the
more people who kind of let us know that
they have XC card the more uh likely we
are to see that and then be able to test
it and do a revisit for you so leave the
comments below subscribe for more as
always go to store. gamas access.net to
grab one of those coaster packs to help
us out directly
and you can go to patreon.com Gamers
Nexus we'll see you all next time